الولايات المتحدة
للأسف دافعت عن حلفائها
عندما كانوا حتى عندما يرتكبون
جرائم حرب الولايات المتحدة
نفسها أه قصفت تعرف المدنيين مما أسفر عن
مقتل الآلاف والرقة في في
سوريا ومول في العراق في الحرب
ضد داعش وطبعا الولايات المتحدة
قتلت المئات  آلاف
الأشخاص خلال حرب فيتنام في القصف
ودعم أه الحكومات القمعية في
أمريكا اللاتينية مثل السلفادور التي
قتلت العشرات والآلاف من
المدنيين هناك أيضا لذا في كثير من النواحي
دعم الولايات المتحدة
لإسرائيل وحملة قصفها
ليس للأسف
مختلف تماما عما شهدناه في
التاريخ الحديث
التاريخ
بالإضافة إلى أنه كان هناك ميل في
الولايات المتحدة والدول الغربية الأخرى
لرؤية الإرهاب الذي يرتكبه
أفراد يحملون
أسلحة أو
متفجرات أه مربوطة على أجسادهم
أو مزروعة في أماكن مختلفة على أنه بطريقة أو بأخرى
أسوأ من ذلك النوع من الإرهاب
الذي يأتي من الطائرات المقاتلة ومن
الصواريخ